what's the vulnerability of a system
like china maybe one way to
say is put china aside and look at
history like a soviet union what's the
vulnerability of a communist
type system well i'll call it both
communist
and
uh autocratic sure
depending on how much autocracy
is that it lacks flexibility
it'll
it
lacks um the ability
um so but i should deal with them
differently um in other words there's
the economic system
the economic system um threatens
motivation
and productivity so communism or
socialism
uh has to be done in a way where
um you can threaten productivity
capitalism has
and what i mean by that i mean free
markets and capital markets
i have been an effective way of
allocating resources
and also creating the
the incentives and the resources
providing the resources for the
inventiveness of new ideas and so if i
compare that
what the chinese have done to a large
extent is to recognize that and have
made a move
that's why the
seeming
dialectic or the conflict between those
two things exists but anyway that's it
as far as an autocratic system
rather than
one man one vote from the population up
the risks of the autocratic system
is that there's enough discontent that
arises
that the
system doesn't have the flexibility
and that rather than bending um it
breaks
um that's that's the big risk
the notion of trying to control a
population
if there's that rather than giving it
the flexibility
so that's the that would be the big risk
of the autocratic system
you